[Música]
la Justicia de Guatemala suspendió la
candidatura presidencial del empresario
Carlos Pineda de Cara a las elecciones
del 25 de junio ahora el ex aspirante
que lideraba las encuestas acusó a la
corte de constitucionalidad de avalar el
fraude electoral Tenemos reporte
luego de que el presidente de México
para usar a las relaciones económicas y
diplomáticas con Perú su homóloga
peruana lo acusó de ignorante nuevo
episodio se produce y luego de que el
congreso de Perú declarara a personas no
ingrata al mandatario mexicano
hay indignación en Estados Unidos luego
de que un agente de la policía le
disparara a un menor de 11 años quien
llamó desde su vivienda para pedir ayuda
por la presencia de un extraño El
oficial fue suspendido mientras se
adelanta la investigación
correspondiente en la familia del niño
pide justicia
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos en
Guatemala donde la corte de
constitucionalidad el máximo tribunal
del país suspendió la candidatura del
empresario Carlos Pineda quien lideraba
las encuestas de Cara a las elecciones
del 25 de junio se trata de una
ratificación de la decisión de una corte
menor que indicó que el partido
prosperidad ciudadana al que pertenece
Pineda incurrió irregularidades en la
proclamación de sus aspirantes
previamente Andrés Suárez Jaramillo
corresponsal de France 24 nos amplió
compineda por fuera como queda el
ajedrez político de los principales
candidatos para suceder Alejandro
yamatei bueno la primera en la lista es
Sandra Torres ella es primera dama de la
nación estuvo casada con Álvaro Colón y
se divorció de él como requisito de ley
para poder lanzar su propia candidatura
a la presidencia Álvaro Colón recordemos
que fue un presidente que estuvo preso
por hechos de corrupción ahora bien el
problema con Sandra Torres es que ha
llegado dos veces a segunda vuelta en
Guatemala en las elecciones con Jimmy
Morales perdió también en las selección
escolar Alejandro yamaté y aquí se dice
que es la candidata más conocida en todo
el país pero la que carga más fuerza de
anti voto lo que se podría llegar a eh
pronosticar es que sí va a llegar a
segunda vuelta y allí Quien llegue a
segunda vuelta puede ser o bien o bien
Suri Ríos no muy conocidos Pero
cualquiera de estos dos candidatos puede
llegar a sostener la segunda vuelta con
Sandra Torres y poder ser el nuevo
presidente de Guatemala
sigue escalando la atención entre Perú y
México este viernes el presidente
mexicano Andrés Manuel López Obrador
decidió romper parcialmente relaciones
con Perú según las palabras textuales
del mandatario Perú es mucho pueblo para
tampoco gobierno Posteriormente la jefa
de estado peruana Dina boluarte lo tildó
de ignorante toda la atención viene en
aumento a partir de las críticas de
López Obrador avoluarte a quien ha
calificado de Usurpadora se ha negado a
entregar la presidencia de la alianza
del Pacífico mientras
no haya normalidad democrática
en Perú
no queremos
este relaciones económicas y comerciales
este con ellos en la madrugada del
viernes autoridades migratorias en
México anunciaron el rescate de más de
100 migrantes en la frontera Sur
viajaban en un tracto camión que
circulaba por el estado de Chiapas y los
agentes reportan que fueron encontrados
en condiciones inhumanas este hallazgo
es uno más de las decenas de casos
similares que suceden en el país Azteca
diariamente y que han aumentado desde el
fin del título 42 en Estados Unidos el
informe es de Max Pérez Gallardo el
tráfico de personas en la frontera sur
de México se recrudece autoridades del
país Azteca encontraron vivos a 175
migrantes en la caja de un camión en el
estado de Chiapas al sur del territorio
mexicano con llantos y golpes al
vehículo los migrantes lograron llamar
la atención de los agentes migratorios
que cuando el vehículo fue detenido en
un retén lograron sacar al centenar de
personas que viaja fascinados el
Instituto Nacional de Migración
autoridad encargada de vigilar los
flujos migratorios en el país publicó un
comunicado anunciando el rescate de los
migrantes con apoyo de la guardia
nacional y la policía estatal el camión
fue llevado a una zona segura donde
fueron contabilizadas 154 personas
originarias de Guatemala 13 de Ecuador
tres del Salvador 3 de Honduras una de
República Dominicana y una de Pakistán
en una situación similar el gobierno
mexicano anunció el rescate de más de 40
migrantes secuestrados en un autobús al
norte del país el presidente Andrés
Manuel López Obrador alertó sobre el
aumento de secuestros a migrantes en
México
que secuestran por eso también
el llamamiento
a los hermanos migrantes
que no se dejen
engañar manipular
por los traficantes las bandas de
contrabandistas de migrantes conocidos
popularmente Como coyotes son individuos
que operan en los pasos fronterizos de
México y que ofrecen llevar a los
migrantes por territorio Azteca
prometiendo el sueño estadounidense un
sueño que muchas veces se convierte en
pesadilla por unanimidad los 400
legisladores del parlamento cubano
aprobaron durante una sesión
extraordinaria la primera Ley de
comunicación social que consagra la
ilegalidad de los medios independientes
que surgieron en internet en la isla no
existen periódicos o canales de
televisión de propiedad privada y los de
mayor alcance pertenecen al partido
comunista más detalles en el siguiente
informe
un voto a mano alzada por unanimidad
para limitar aún más la libertad de
expresión en Cuba el parlamento aprobó
una ley llamada de comunicación social
que prohíbe los medios de comunicación
independientes en toda la isla Ahora
sólo se permiten los medios controlados
por el estado es hora de comprender y
emplear todos los recursos de la
comunicación Social para favorecer la
participación la transparencia la
rendición de cuentas para poner en común
es decir unir todos nuestros
conocimientos en función de extraer las
mejores ideas
articularnos y generar consensos con el
auge de internet los últimos años han
visto surgir varios medios de
comunicación en línea de tendencia muy
crítica hacia el poder comunista un
ejemplo es 14 y medio fundado en 2014 y
cuya línea editorial se considera
subversiva varios de sus periodistas
abandonaron el país en 2022 debido a las
múltiples presiones a las que desean
estar sometidos
publicar noticias en estas condiciones
es lamentable no solo hay que soportar
la represión y las amenazas sino que a
menudo te impiden salir de casa o cuando
lo haces te detienen y te cortan
internet la ley también refuerza el
control del Estado sobre las redes
sociales a partir de ahora cualquier
comentario publicado o simplemente
compartido que llame a la subversión del
orden constitucional será considerado un
delito grave castigado con penas de
prisión la comunidad afroamericana es el
grupo étnico con mayores tasas de
ataques fatales con armas de fuego por
parte de la policía en Estados Unidos
según datos recopilados de los últimos
seis años un niño de 11 años de
Mississippi estuvo cerca de sumarse a
esta estadística luego de que el oficial
que Atendió una llamada de emergencia en
su casa abriera Fuego contra él
humanizada nos cuenta más
un disparo en el pecho
de 11 años llamó a la policía por
indicaciones de su madre ante la
presencia de un intruso el fin de semana
en su casa de indianola Mississippi una
comunidad de mayoría afroamericana a 160
kilómetros de Jackson pero el niño
terminó recibiendo un disparo por parte
del oficial que fue atender los hechos
él dijo salga con las manos arriba en
ese momento mi hijo salió salir con las
manos en alto y que te disparen no lo
entiendo
el niño estuvo cinco días hospitalizado
por la herida con un pulmón colapsado
laceraciones en el hígado y una costilla
fracturada El oficial gregps fue
retirado de servicio activo mientras es
investigado pero a un goza de sueldo
familiares y vecinos de Adrián
protestaron frente al ayuntamiento de
indianola
pedimos justicia un niño afroamericano
de 11 años estuvo a centímetros de
perder la vida no hizo nada malo hizo
todo bien
Qué amenaza suponía él es claramente un
bebé y tú eres un veterano oficial de
policía entrenado que parte de tu
entrenamiento te hace pensar que ese
bebé era una amenaza para ti
la familia ha pedido que se publique el
video de la cámara corporal del oficial
y que este se ha despedido y acusado de
asalto agravado Mississippi se ha visto
sacudido en días recientes por otro caso
de uso de fuerza letal por parte de la
policía en contra de un ciudadano
afroamericano tres ex oficiales tendrán
que enfrentar cargos criminales por la
muerte en custodia de un hombre de 41
años atacado en repetidas ocasiones con
una pistola de aturdimiento durante un
arresto es todo por el momento en France
24 gracias por su sintonía
[Música]